[Música]
la provincia del estado libre es una de
las más pobres de sudáfrica
sylvester está desempleado siempre ha
vivido aquí en las pequeñas casas que
otrora se llamaban cajas de vosotros
estas casas que fueron construidas bajo
el apartheid nunca fueron renovadas sus
techos son en asbesto el material
prohibido hoy en día en las
construcciones en europa porque es
considerado como cáncer y aquí todo el
mundo está igual y les prometieron
nuevas viviendas pero siguen viviendo en
condiciones desastrosas
es peligroso porque se le agregó un
producto químico de condis y es algo que
puede dar de beber culos y cosas
imposibles que provienen del techo y se
atribuyen en este afán surge esa muerte
de seguro fondues win to win the space
están inquietos por su salud y
frustrados por las promesas el vecino de
matthew vive aquí desde hace 50 años
dice que una sociedad por fin vino a
hacer una cotización en 2015 para
cambiar su techo pero nada más
ello en los periódicos que más de 10
millones de euros desapareció
estamos molestos pero no sabemos qué
hacer y tomaron el dinero destinado a
nuestras casas y dónde está ese dinero
y nosotros viviendo aquí en estas
condiciones que los metan a la cárcel en
chip
y fungicidas de hachís
entonces fueron a manifestar el pasado
mes de octubre delante de la sede de la
a en ese el partido en el poder para
denunciar la corrupción están molestos
con el ism a gasol en aquella época era
gobernador de la provincia del estado
en cuanto tengamos información tenemos
los números telefónicos de sus
dirigentes locales podemos transmitirles
nuestras instrucciones
el responsable de la amc se declara y no
sé sin embargo se sospecha que desvió
dinero público y no solamente en el
ámbito de las viviendas en su libro
titulado el estado gángster este
periodista fue el primero que reveló la
dimensión de la corrupción del patrón de
la provincia del estado libre y ellos
desde sus inicios en el poder cuando era
ministro provincial de agricultura
en 2005 fue a la universidad agrícola de
clint en la periferia de pronto una
propiedad del estado si una universidad
pública que forma a la gente en
agricultura vaya ya sea batir las vacas
el ganado que se encuentra ahí
conectarse empacar la carne y la hace
entregar en una conferencia de la amc
con el fin de comprar el apoyo de sus
facciones una vez más ello fue una señal
que las autoridades nacionales deberían
haber detectado este hombre no es digno
de confianza pero a pesar de ello pudo
continuar su ascenso en las instancias
provinciales
su ascenso provincial luego nacional fue
fulgurante repartiendo regalos a sus
copartidarios e isma de azules se volvió
cada vez más popular sus relaciones con
en cosas sanas uma la ex esposa de jacob
zuma quien se había presentado a la
presidencia de la anr
17 le permitieron subir en la jerarquía
del partido en el poder hoy en día es
secretario general de la amc
[Música]
es maga zuliano dirige más la provincia
del estado libre pero en las zonas
rurales aún se habla de como también era
cercano de los hermanos gupta acusado de
corrupción con el antiguo presidente
jacob zuma también está implicado en
numerosos contratos estaba por ejemplo
la finca es tina una empresa lechera que
tendría que haber beneficiado a los más
desfavorecidos pero los hermanos gupta
se embolsillaron las ayudas del estado
sin desarrollar nada nuevo este
escándalo choca a todas las comunidades
françois sólo está instalado en la
región se demoró 15 años creando un
ganado de calidad sabe lo difícil que es
el acceso a la tierra
que esté en agua christina estaba basado
en un modelo lanzado en india
qué es una buena iniciativa
antes dos años después me enteré de que
estaba muriendo y que ya no había fondos
para comprar forraje
por eso es un frenesí desvía el dinero
destinado a las comunidades para llenar
[Música]
ok
tras años de investigación e isma
gazules compareció finalmente ante el
tribunal de blomfontein junto con siete
coacusados están inculpados por
corrupción fraude robo y blanqueo de
dinero su proceso comenzará en febrero
si ciertos militantes reclaman justicia
temen que el poderoso partido en el
poder caiga como un juego de dominó si
el número 3 de la amc es encarcelado en
el último comité ejecutivo del partido
el presidente ramaphosa no se guardó las
palabras
stones
confirmamos nuestra posición de firmeza
frente a la corrupción y las fechorías
que existen en nuestras filas esto es
vital para el renacimiento de nuestra
organización y para restaurar su
credibilidad ante los sudafricanos la
prioridad de cyril ramaphosa es
restaurar la confianza de los
sudafricanos pero el camino por recorrer
sigue siendo largo para que el partido
de nelson mandela recupere su
credibilidad